on passe ici à l'espace dédié aux
différentes activités
c'est ici dans ce local 100 mètres
carrés du quartier des friches de
maurepas qu'une mosquée verra le jour
d'ici le mois de juin
un chantier de 17000 euros entièrement
financés par l'association des musulmans
de maurepas qui a déjà levé la moitié
des fonds la première fonction de ce
mieux l'un va être un lieu d'activités
culturelles et un lieu d'activités
culturelles aussi pour une raison très
simple parce que là où vous avez du
culte vous avez un local qui est ouvert
pratiquement toute la semaine donc plus
accessible et donc on peut être plus
réactif en cas de problème quand il faut
éventuellement faire quelque chose' la
vie vis-à-vis de nos jeunes une salle de
prière avec un espace pour les hommes et
pour les femmes
calligraphie apprentissage de la langue
arabe au cours de civisme
les activités seront dispensés par
plusieurs associations de la ville
grosso modo ça va bénéficier à peu près
à 82 familles
donc quand on dise 80 familles c'est à
la fois des personnes adultes qui
pourront venir faire leurs prières ici
mais aussi les jeunes de ces familles là
qui auront comme je voulais dit un local
dédié à pas mal d'activités qui vont les
qui va les concerner auparavant les
musulmans de maurepas devait se rendre
dans les mosquées d'eads en cours
l'objectif de mostefa ouvrir le local
pour le début du mois de ramadan